oh
o o
[Musique]
là
le floch prigent
quand on est capitaine dadis est comme
vous l'avez été est-ce que la fin
justifie tous les moyens n'ont pas tous
les moyens mais beaucoup de moyens oui
mais qu'à dire que notre notre souci
quand et d'industrie c'est de faire
marcher entreprises et faire marcher
l'entreprise bien ça nécessite de faire
un certain nombre de choses qui sont pas
forcément morale pas forcément morale
c'est à dire c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
on considère qu'il faut absolument
réaliser une opération on est on est sur
le fil de la bonne morale classique le
désert est-ce que vous calculer la part
du risque entre ce qui est moral et
immoral non non non non essentiellement
gagner pas à tout prix
encore une fois jusqu'à un certain point
c'est à dire que non quand quand il y a
des le mort d'hommes possible
bien évidemment la fille c'est la ligne
la mort d'hommes seuls dhimmitude tout
le reste on peut l'utiliser
toutes les armes sont valables oui elles
sont utilisées et mais pas seulement par
nos capitaines d'industrie elles sont
utilisées en politique aussi
là on les avait érigé on en parlait mais
vous avez dirigé les grandes entreprises
rhône poulenc elf est la sncf gdf et à
chaque fois vous avez utilisé les mêmes
méthodes
ah non pas du tout parce que les
réalités sont complètement différentes
mais ce que je viens de dire c'est que
il faut réussir dire que nous sommes
jugés sur leurs résultats
la morale n'a rien à voir avec les
affaires absolument nous sommes jugés
sur leurs résultats d'accor donc il faut
contrairement à ce qui existe
aujourd'hui journalistique mans hier que
dire oui s'il faut faire ça parce que
c'est bien parce que c'est mal il faut
là non on n'est plus là dedans
pathétiquement correct il peut pas y
avoir d'accord il ne peut y avoir que le
résultat et la capacité d'arriver au
résultat et vous vous avez toujours
employer ces méthodes là j'ai employé
les méthodes qu'ils me considèrent que
je considérais parfaitement justifiée
le biais d'entreprises d'ailleurs que le
bien de l'entreprise est l'élément
essentiel
donc est ce que l'entreprise va marcher
ou pas et dans ce cas si jamais j'ai
trouvé le moyen de la faire marcher
mieux je vais jusqu'au bout
sauf d'ici ça nécessite mort d'homme si
ça nécessite révolution si cela
nécessite a donc là on n'avait pas revu
corner
vous avez connu mort d'anna j'ai connu
j'ai connu mort d'homme c'est à dire que
lorsque nous avons été en angola on a
avec elf elf
nous avions là la nécessité de protéger
notre personnel et par conséquent nous
l'avons rassemblés au moment parce que
je vais la guerre civile nous avons
rassemblé en un lieu et on avait
également une sorte de deux grands de
grandes possibilités d'aller sur la mer
est en principe tout le monde allait en
voiture mais les voitures étaient
protégés ont pour aller de l'avant et un
jour il ya une femme une femme qui qui a
été tout seul on sait pas pourquoi elle
s'est arrêtée ce service on sait pas
pourquoi elle est morte
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement préoccupant pour un jeu en
2d est ce que j'ai fait quelque chose
qui a conduit à mort d'homme en
l'occurrence il s'est trouvé que il
n'avait pas de ça n'existait pas vous
avez dit la morale est incompatible avec
les affaires l'industrie la marche
industriels je sais que vous intéresser
beaucoup à l'industrie aujourd'hui où la
commenter est ce que le politiquement
correct justement a tué l'industrie
française
on sait pas seulement politique encore
c'est le fait qu' on considère que
l'industrie et est immoral d'une façon
générale et qu'on avait plus envie
d'industrie donc il ya eu toute une
période en france où on vous dirait que
les patrons étaient des et qu'il
fallait les et qu'il fallait en
l'air donc donc cette française
aujourd'hui on la baie on l'a perdu la
bataille non fondées la bataille on a on
a perdu la moitié de la bataille
grossièrement on a on a diminué
on a divisé par deux en 30 ans
l'industrie parce qu'on a considéré que
la crise était sale
c'était pas bien et que les jeunes
entreprises c'était des gens pas bien et
donc aujourd'hui on est dans cette
situation c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que nous avons une administration qui
essayent de nous faire partir à
l'étranger
c'est ça que c'est ça la réalité c'est
ça il ya plus grands industriels en
france aujourd'hui il ya des groupes
industriels de qualité qui continue à
exister
- photo c'est assez surprenant vous êtes
plutôt un homme de gauche
oui vous êtes un homme de gauche
revendique et oui revendiquent eux il ya
un homme que vous appréciez
oui je sais pas si vous le connaissez
mais vous êtes vous l'appréciez vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez écrit oui
absolument bernard arnault oui pour vous
c'est l'incarnation de l'industrie
française non non c'est l'incarnation
d'une partie de l'entreprenariat
français accor qui a pris un objectif le
luxe et qu'il a travaillé au point
d'être une des premières entreprises
mondiales sur le sujet c'est un
entrepreneur français
l'industrie c'est pour moi c'est plus
manufacturier est ce que j'aurais aimé
chez bernard arnault c'est que il
il ay un peu plus sur ce terrain là sur
ce terrain de la manufacture et du
rapatriement de la manufacture à
l'intérieur des frontières
mais ça va arriver parce qu'il va voir
que son intérêt loïk le floch prigent
pour réussir dans le monde de
l'industrie
est-ce qu'il faut être complice du
pouvoir politique non mais en il faut le
comprendre et vous vous avez été
complices du pouvoir politique
pourquoi non j'ai été j'ai été j'ai été
proche de mitterrand et c'est mitterand
qui m'a confié à un moment à 38 ans les
rênes d'une entreprise que je
n'imaginais pas que tu aies rhône
poulenc
c'est une mort qui vous a mis sur la
roue heureusement a complètement c'est
lui qui m'a mis sur la rampe de
lancement
alors après j'avais une un respect
filial pour ce pour ce personnage que
j'ai trouvé fascinant et qui est le seul
patron j'ai eu
vous avez fait tourner le système
mitterrand windson façon bien sûr bien
sûr et vous qu'il l'avait fait tourner
sur le plan économique sur le patio
financiers essentiellement pas
financiers essentiellement industrielle
ceyzériat sur l'industrie j'avais mon à
dire quel que soit le sujet sur lequel
mitterrand
développer sans arrêt g il m'appelait où
je donnais mon point de vue où les
attend alors après il suivait où il
suivait pas je ne dis pas que toutes les
décisions de mitterrand pour les miens
bien au contraire
vous avez participé vous étiez la
cheville ouvrière de son système et
industriels absolument c'est ça il a
embarqué là-dedans finalement embarquer
là dedans oui ils m'ont marqué là dedans
parce que en bien ou en mal
ah ben moi je trouve ça bien c'est moi
j'ai une vie passionnante oui mais là
vous avez payé 1
oui j'ai payé alors c'est le jeu c'est
le problème le problème de ce qui m'est
arrivé n'est pas le problème d'une
plainte sur moi ouais c'est la plainte
que j'ai c'est que je considère que ma
famille était maltraitée par
l'environnement d'accord aussi bien
politiques que le boisement des affaires
donc j'en veux globalement si j'en veux
à quelqu'un aux politiques et au monde
des affaires vis-à-vis de ma famille
vis-à-vis de moi bon je savais que comme
je les écris j'étais le mouton noir
bon un moment un moment j'avais pensé
son expression de mouton noir pourquoi
ils vous appellent le bouton noir parce
qu'à chaque fois que ce quelque chose il
dit ah c'est loïc qui a dit ça et les
types 10 mais non il faut pas le suivre
il comprend rien tard ans et en
particulier tout le monde énarchique que
et le monde des grands corps de l'état
uzi bon c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
réussi à 18 ans un concours que ils sont
les meilleurs
aujourd'hui j'ai souvenir dans un beau
livre je crois qu'il s'appelle le mouton
noir d'ailleurs vous à ses débuts livre
à vous arrivez dans son bureau il dit ah
tiens là le mouton noir
c'est à mes enfants qui dit ça il disait
ça tout est ce que c'est en série tous
essaient mais s'aimer mais à mes enfants
alors quand qu'est ce que ça fait d'être
le fils ou la fille du mouton noir à mes
enfants à ussel est ce que vous faisiez
week oblige en f
c'était la vache à lait de la république
n'ont pas la vache à lait c'était le
c'était la capacité de
[Musique]
de faire une politique alternative à
l'intérieur des pays où nous étions en
particulier l'afrique
donc c'était c'était écrit par le de
gaulle guillaume a le bras politique
française en afrique absolument et donc
quand je suis arrivé à décoloniser après
la décolonisation sur un certain nombre
de pays africains le de dirigeants d'elf
du pays était un espèce de deuxième
ambassadeur est souvent le quand
j'arrivais dans le pays istres plutôt à
l'aller plutôt que d'aller chez
l'ambassadeur s'était l'ambassadeur qui
venait chez moi et qui est qu'ils
veulent parce que c'était moi qui avais
les moyens
alors donc ça ferait afrique c'était
c'est alors la france avis que j'aime
pas ce mot non le mot que j'aime c'est
on a une politique africaine où on a pas
on veut développer on veut pas
développer et qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
et sa menace par la corruption ça passe
par des pots de vin ce alors sa position
alors la rétrocommission absolue ça
passe par le fait qu' on avait
l'ambition de garder en afrique une
certaine stabilité et que cette
stabilité nécessitait qu'elles soient
sauvegardés pour c'est à dire que le
chef de l'état qui était là puissent
rester un certain temps et qui est pas
des putschs sans arrêt dans l'ordre
plutôt que le chaos
voilà donc on nous a demandé on nous a
demandé tous là moi et les gens des
services et à tout le monde
est-ce qu'on peut au moins conserver
quelques chefs d'état stable pendant un
certain temps mais c'est ça que nous
avons fait il ya et à ce moment là à ce
moment là pour les garder comme on est
dans une dans un système tribal
il faut que le chef de tribu en
l'occurrence le président est un peu
d'argent et il faut lui trouver un peu
d'argent
c'est comme ça ça commence sincèrement
d'avoir cet argent là oui il va aux
chefs d'état africains aux hommes en
place
mais il va aussi dans les caisses des
partis politiques français
alors après après c'est les chefs d'état
en question qui remettent qui remettent
de l'argent et des politiques pour pour
en se disant si jamais il ya un
changement de majorité un changement les
autres il faut que je reste en place
d'allier l'art conséquent par conséquent
ils vont y aviez et mitterrand aussi
parce que vous avez parlé avec lui que
un peu d'argent à l'est dans la
nébuleuse que vous appelez la nébuleuse
chirac au pasqua yens oui non mais vous
avez laissé faire
c'est à dire que littéraire vous a dit
où on continue oui hé hé hé hé il savait
combien parce que c'est parce que
c'était parce que à l'époque combien
c'était un jeu pas de souvenirs bien sûr
mais disons que à l'époque nous mettions
tous que tout ce qui était fait à la
direction du budget et c'est le
président donc on avait une feuille de
papier sur laquelle il y avait voilà
combien a été donnée à monsieur x
monsieur y mettant qu'elle faisait ça et
aidants et c'était donc c'était opaque
par rapport à la population
immoral bon patient mais c'était
transparent avons aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus ouais vous
êtes sûr donc ça existe mais c'est
complètement opaque d'accord et c'est
plus transparent alors planque donc on a
pris un système immoral riz était
transparent et on l'a remplacé par un
système immoral qui ne l'est plus loin
en disant on est transparent pour faire
ça il faut des hommes de confiance
oui ils vous ont travaillé ces hommes là
oui y'en a un qui vous a travaillé
notamment
vous connaissez bien oui alfred sirven
oui andré tarallo oui dédé la sardine
vous souvenez mais andré guelfi
ils nous ont trahis oui bien sûr vous
ont trahi votre confiance à ils ont
trahi ma confiance mais c'est quoi ils
ont pris du pognon pour eux oui ils sont
allés parler un peu en ville oui et puis
ils ont ils ont dit que c'était pour moi
ce qui était embêtant ouais en fait en
fait vous avez payé mais vous n'avez
rien gagné
ah non non non non ça c'est en argent
sonnant et trébuchant rien d'ailleurs
comme c'est parce que été placée mal
payés c'est parce que absolument oui
enfin 2d dès que mon successeur est
arrivé il a pris tel salaire mais la
risée c'était dans les conditions d'or
non mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est que pour arriver à condamner les
gens qui aient pris de l'argent
il fallait qu'on année le donneur
d'ordre qui est des mois donc on n'avait
pas le choix
la justice n'avait pas le choix et il
fallait me salir et comme et comme
finalement après la mort de mitterrand
tout le monde avait envie de me salir
parce que posent ils vous ont fait aussi
gti l'étranger le blazer toute la gauche
française comme à tomber dessus et vos
collaborateurs et mon collaborateur où
on va ils sont venus
connaissiez pas pour certains d'entre
eux christine deviers joncour qui était
très intense c'est rien de roland dumas
j'ai vu une fois le problème c'est vous
avez chuté avec ce système là quand il
avait mise à jour oui ils étaient mises
au jour par don par eux par vos
collaborateurs par des airs et amy il
était mon par les politiques dont je
pense que si vous voulez si jamais si
jamais il y avait eu une complicité
entre entre moi et balladur ça n'aurait
pas lieu c'était la confiance est l
inverse qui existait ce cas palpable et
noël c'est l'entourage de la dure c'est
balladur oui bien sûr mais surtout
balladur il vous nomme après chirac qui
vous rattrape
c'est non c'est mitterand qui imposa
balladur qu'en partant de l jayas de
france celui qui impose balladur n'était
pas du tout à la ruhr et ensuite lorsque
il ya la grève de 95 chirac m'appelle
les est ce que vous voulez arrêter la
base et donc et donc gérer les acteurs
ou suivraient et donc j'y vais je suis
pompier bon et essai et je ne regrette
pas c'est à dire que ça a été un des
moments les plus passionnants de ma vie
c'est à dire avoir une entreprise avec
un un mot tu y vas sont énormes des
cheminots ce que je connaissais pas et
et c'est l'entreprise qui qui comprenait
pas ce qui lui arrivait et pour moi ça a
été un magnifique
après ça serai moins gai alors après
sans moyens louis loiselle non fondées
ou non on la connaît on a collé oui eva
joly oui c'est ça l'art c'est étonnant
parce que l'eba jolie aile et de votre
famille plus ou mois c'était une jeune
fille au pair séquentielle de violence
chez des cousins éloignés chez des
cousins éloignés elle a épousé le père
de famille non elle épousait le profit
ces négos fils aîné et elle le savait
que vous étiez de la même famille quand
on sera pas lâché 1 à banon mais c'est à
dire que j'étais la proie qui lui
permettait de faire carrière
alors mon c'est très bien aveugle c'est
comme ça et c'était adoubé par tout le
monde puisque et la gauche et la droite
avait envie de se séparer de moi vers la
gauche c'est pas un petit fou oui même
si la gauche veut et qui vous aideront à
la gauche
tout le monde tout tous les anciens
trotskistes autour de jospin voir jospin
notamment jose par mu c'est la gauche
morale c'est la gauche morale la gauche
morale pouvais pas me ferais ça c'est et
la droite morale non plus la ouate moral
non plus alors après la dure à la dure a
été a été a été odieux c'est clair et
mais disons que des gens comme comme
sarkozy par exemple était d'une
neutralité totale
il ya eu dans à droite des gens qui ont
dit non bah écoutez c'est débrouillez
vous avec vos avec vos types alors la
gauche morale dont vous parlez elle se
manifeste en fait après la mort de
françois mitterrand ou quand ils deux
jours de l'asem concerne jeunes en
janvier 96 sais c'est le jour de la mort
vaut aujourd'hui à la gauche morale
commence à me tuer ça veut dire que
mitterrand était vivant il me protégeait
mais le jour où il meurt le jour où il
meurt c'est ça veut dire comité rose et
cette bourse et la gauche immoral sais
pas si c'est la gauche mais c'est
forcément c'est cynique une agro
chimique j'aimerais mieux même le
cynisme c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que oui mais sauf que mais les
fondations
mais il défend la nation et il défend la
liberté moi je considère que la liberté
est fondamental est que depuis la mort
de mitterrand
nous allons de liberticide en
liberticide l'esprit de liberté chez
chez mitterrand était fondamental à
chaque fois qu'on le connaît depuis hier
on n'est pas libre ça c'est contre la
liberté et herat c'était l'éruption et
vice versa et quelques quelques liberté
absolue elle qui était pas très réglo
donc et après et après ils défendent la
liberté et je considère qu'aujourd'hui
avec la gauche morale la droite morale
la morale finalement on arrive à dire
n'en faisait pas droit vous êtes unis
vous avez pas droit vous n'avez pas de
nostalgiques des périodes oui bien sûr
bon d'accord
eva joly combien de mise en examen 28
elle était vêtue de son cas de séjour en
prison
vous avez fait oui combien de mois de
prison 28 eur 2 en deux ans deux ans et
demi de prison mais la série da oui oui
oui mais attention c'est rude parce que
pendant que vous êtes en prison ont
détruit votre famille je détruis vous
aussi votre réputation alors il avait vu
un capitaine d'animaux favorisant ils
ont ils ont du mal aujourd'hui à dire
que que d'autres ont réussi alors que
j'ai réussi tout ce que j'ai fait
réussir le plan social fritel j'ai
réussi à gaz de france gdf areva moyart
et puis avec les moyens et c'est ce que
ce que nous avons fait à mon poulain par
exemple c'était on avait une cgt qui
était absolument impossible à gérer
et vous les lavez je suis allé voir
krasucki ouais je lui dis bon comme on
travaille le pouvoir aussi ces voix là
il y avait deux parties personne n'y a
pas eu de c'est pas du tout non mais si
non que j'aie juillet voilà comment on
peut travailler
voilà ce que j'ai envie de faire est ce
que ça te choque ou aussi c'est le choc
discutons-en et on a trouvé les
solutions et au fond de votre cellule
alors au fond de masse et je suis
malheureux non pas à cause de moi parce
que sur la leur ai dit de même aimé la
façon dont on traite ma famille oui
c'est à dire que je ne vois pas en quoi
le fait d'avoir été un bon patron et
d'être et d'avoir un difficultés avec la
justice peut conduire mouvement ma
famille a à être complètement mise au
rancart et je n'admets pas ça la façon
la façon dont seront donc par exemple ma
mère a été convoqué et en garde à vue
j'ai c'est odieux
c'est odieux c'est aussi ma bellaïd
bonne deuxième épouse a eu des problèmes
aussi que vous lui aviez accorder des
lignes de crédit c'est pas tellement moi
qui ai fait ça c'est qui qu'a fait ça
c'est mes collaborateurs c'est eux qui
lui avait accordé bien sûr mais c'est
vous qui payez non c'est la société
non mais qui paye et judiciairement vu
un film sur cette affaire qui s'appelle
l'ivresse du pouvoir
oui alors allié fidèle ce film
non tout du tout reconnaissez pas dedans
non non mais madame joly a cru que
c'était moi qui l'avais inspiré par ce
qu'elle considère être maltraités dans
ce film alors bon alors savez vous
considérez vous avez été maltraités
aussi non j'ai une facture berléand qui
l'a dit c'est à dire berléand non berlin
est un très bon acteur
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt sympathique de
s'appeler berlin revient et simplement
je trouve que bon il dit qu' il sait que
j'ai du psoriasis tongs et sans arafat
se gratter la barbe c'est pas vraiment
mon cas il vivait avec sérieux ça
voilà je dis avec force voilà donc c'est
à l'époque on me dit va y avoir un film
sur vous et le réalisateur dit j'ai pas
envie de vous voir très bien parfait et
ensuite la justice a essayé de voir
combien j'avais été payé pour ce film
parce qu'il considérait que je j'avais
été j'ai même pas vu 0 vous l'avez pas
vu le film
si in anger je n'ai pas vu le
réalisateur je vous avais jamais libéré
en non plus je zéro centime alors ils
ont fouillé pendant des mois et des mois
pour essayer de savoir examinons on va
trouver quelque chose
il n'a pas payé dans la lah et voilà
c'est ça le fait d'avoir eu cette
réputation d'être vénale a conduit les
gens à considérer que j'étais j'ai
j'avais envie d'argent la vallée
d'argent et je m'en fous complètement
et elle veut souviens encore quand on
disait vous allez dans l'hôtel dans les
palaces canada foot mans elles étaient
sans abri et vous traîner dans les
palaces après chose qui vous a peut-être
aidé à surmonter ces épreuves terribles
vous êtes éloigné de la religion à cette
eau mais dieu jamais c'est une phrase
que vous avez écrites très tôt je
m'éloigne de la religion mais pas de
dieu selon dieu il vous habite
oui il vous aide oui il vous prend par
la main prend par la main son bord nancy
l'écart de la caisse qui sait quoi dieu
pour vous je bossais
il ya forcément une explication au fait
qu'on soit là et il ya forcément quelque
chose qu el khadra qui a conduit à la
situation en est aujourd'hui
d'accord on que donc c'est donc il
s'occupe pas de nous enfin je n'ai pas
le sentiment qu'ils occupent de nous
comme comme les un certain nombre de
gens le pensent mais on a une mission
sur terre on a des talents il faut
exploiter les talents et développer une
partition mois cet hiver
et moi je considère que je suis
industriel je bâtis l'industrie j'ai
bâti d'industrie et dès que j'ai pu
après ces épreuves dont vous parlez j'ai
voulu rebâtir quelque chose était donc
et je suis toujours de cette phase
malgré malgré la pression s'est passé je
suis là pour bâtir une industrie parce
que je sais faire
j'aime ça et je choisirai absolument
essentielle pour le pays alors un
j'écris 2 je suis industrielle toujours
3 parle de temps en temps en particulier
les médias verra dans les médias parce
que je veux faire comprendre aux gens
que c'est l'industrie qui va les sauver
alors il ya un pilier capitale pour vous
vous avez cité son nom tout à l'heure
parce que c'est ça qui vous a fait du
mal
c'est la famille votre famille ce que
parce que pas un arbre dont ma mère
parlait dans vos livres de votre grand
mère de vos grands-parents la bretagne
la bretagne
votre femme marlène surtout qui vous a
tenu soutenu me incroyable elle vous à
un bijou et puis une chose alors
étonnante votre passion pour la pêche à
pied ou alors alors vous êtes breton
c'est pas très étonnant non plus mais
vous l'avez je dirais vous avez écrit
des livres là dessus écrit un livre en
prison c'est sur wii arrive en prison et
en m après un série de livres et voilà
alors ce seront là c'est la bretagne
vous reconnaissez c'est quoi sa lancée
des sept-îles non mais c'est ça donc on
est dans la région de trébeurden lors
d'un trait les roses guéret grosse gaye
lanriec et landrellec faut pas oublier
parce que c'est un pleumeur bodou vrai
qu'en bon jour d'août
et qui est un paradis un paradis alors
on va regarder les deux livres que vous
avez écrit qu'ils sont des petits
fascicules à la fois sur la corse est
alors là vous avez le premier c'est la
crevette et jean mignon c'est à dire
c'est la pêche à la crevette et les
jambes non c'est à dire que la terre
nous sommes nous donne des choses
extraordinaires
jeudi la crevette et et champigny vous
l'avez écrit en prison en prison en
prison deux ans et le deuxième le
deuxième j'ai écrit alors que la pêche à
pied le guide à pêche à pied en bretagne
c'est une commande d des gens de coop
breizh d'auditeurs qui ont demandé est
ce que vous voulez faire ça et pourquoi
parce que vous êtes un des dix personnes
les plus connus qui avaient la grand
nombre d'élèves de pêche à pied dit oui
j'en ai j'en ai un grand nom et là je
suis avec avec ma nièce qui est une
femme qui une femme 4 1 mais qui acquit
à vista la pêche à pied absolument
extraordinaire et ça quand on est un
homme de pouvoir et vous vous êtes un
homme de pouvoir
vous l'avez été aurélien wii wheel est
encore oui bien sûr il faut un dérivatif
comme ça des railleries l'état il faut
des pressions il faut des passions dire
qu'on ne peut pas être industrielle au
niveau je suis sans passion bon allez
mais cette passion-là elle elle
conduirait à l'extinction de la passion
des rsa vous vous prendrez donc il faut
avoir des choses des choses à côté et
est donc pour moi la bretagne la pêche à
pied
c'est fondamental j'ai toujours mon
petit guide démarré avec moi pour savoir
connaissez par coeur les heures des
marées
oui au pot parker enfin nouveau faux-pas
loi va je vous savez ce sont les grandes
marécageux c'est là il ya une marée de
coefficient là bas et en septembre et le
coefficient de marée en octobre enfin
que je sais la marine devait prendre les
coefficients faire 114 115 de l'éco
efficience et de 20 à 120 1 donc donc
donc on rapproche de 120 on va plus loin
sur l'estran et par conséquent on peut
prendre plus de choses et c'est
passionnant parce que c'est un des
endroits qu'ils ont découvert que très
peu et le pouvoir
c'est comme les marais ça monte ça
descend oui mais
la prononcer le pouvoir sur pour moi
c'est de pouvoir sur le l'avenir du pays
et l'avenir industriel du pays c'est ça
c'est ça qui m'intéresse faire que
comment arriver à faire comprendre aux
gens que l'industrie est importante pour
leur vie une partie de leurs difficultés
aujourd'hui en particulier en ce qui
concerne le chauffage vient du fait que
l'industrie a disparu et deux que on
peut faire quelque chose
si jamais on a envie on peut voir
quelque chose est apte à complètement je
suis vraiment monsieur français français
à l'industrie française
la dijonnaise gagnant gagne et et je ne
crois pas à la à l'industrie européenne
je crois je crois à l'industrie
française qui s'allie avec d'autres
européens pour faire des choses
intelligentes mais je pense qu'il faut
avoir un fonds français beaucoup plus
important est que aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que il n'ya pas
suffisamment d'investisseurs français
qui rendent dans l'essai français c'est
ça le sujet et vous vous investissez
dans l'industrie a reculé
bien sûr tout ce que j'ai vous allez
encore de l'argent un peu plus ma femme
votre femme d'accord et femme devra
investir à evry voilà d'accord annoncés
si c'était bon boudin il ya des
conditions d'âge pour être pdg d'un
grand groupe
vous pourriez de paix déjà un gros coup
je suis trop vieux
enfin entre mois on ferait quoi je sais
faire quand je vois un certain nombre de
pdg aujourd'hui l'a dit c'est quand même
difficile de faire pire
d'accord un donc elle est donc voilà on
né sait qu'on a un gros c j'ai plutôt
prendre lança s'avère payant il reste
encore quelques présidents qui sont de
qualité quelques-uns et on est content
les avoir ils vont à voile à rennes ils
prennent conseiller auprès de vous non
pas très peu très peu si c'était à
refaire tout ça vous feriez avec les
mêmes l'épreuve
oui ah ouais ah oui moi j'ai une belle
vie
non mais est ce que vous avez réussi
votre vie oui est ce que je me suis
jamais plaint j'ai écrit ce que vous
avez entendu une plainte de moins sur
moi non
bon voila j'ai joué le terrain la seule
plainte que j'ai et je le répète
excusez moi de me répéter c'est pourquoi
on voit traiter ma famille se sont
expliqués mois expliquez moi madame joly
dans pourquoi votre démarche est inapte
à son merci loïk le floch prigent
[Musique]